何のこともなく それぐらいもう簡単なことなんです
で そこでどういう働きかというと
やっぱり心のこのカラクリなんですね
で まあそこら辺をあんなにアビダルマ勉強していてないんだけど
人々はいくらかは分かってるんです
ですから このいろんなところでね
金集める噂ね もう大変身についているのは
確実にその人々の名誉欲
褒めてほしいという欲とかね
認めてほしいという欲を
あの欲にあの反応して何とかすることだけなんですね
で それでこの本当にこの地と法の行をするのは難しいということ
たまたまあのこうもなるんです
例えばお布施をすると
それによって結果はあんまりにも希望すると
褒めてほしいとかね 認めてほしいと
宣伝してほしいと その気持ちは強烈
で まあまあ 僕らはもうずっとまあお寺のまあ宗教関係の生活だから
まあそういうことというのは
まあよくあの直接的な経験で知ってるしね
で 何とかの活動に人のね
まあ寄付やら何とか欲しい場合はね
大体のこの商売やってる人やらね
お金ある人々やらね あんまりにも宣伝してあげないと
褒めてあげないと わずかな寄付でもしない
ですから 大変ね 問題ですけど
そこでいろいろ活動を始めたら
どうしても活動はしなくちゃいけないし
それには資金必要であるし
そこでお金持ってる人々にはお願いしなくちゃいけないし
お願いする場合はもう徹底的にその人々を褒めてあげたりして
宣伝したりして 認めてあげたりしてあげないとやってくれない
ですから 例えばお寺の何かに寄付したら
必ずその人の名前をもう何かに看板に書いて彫って置いておくとかね
するんですね それでなければ
もうそれでもたまに喧嘩するんです
なんであの人の名前を上に書いたんですかとかね
そういう見解になります
お坊さんたちっていうのは
人々をコントロールするのも世界一上手なんです
みんな綺麗にバカにするんです
で まああまりそういう
まあそういう問題が出てくるんだけど
ちょっと一言でそれはもう取り消しにしますけどね
でも若いお坊さんたちとか
たまたまね 大変なトラブル起こしたりはするんです
まあその時はまあどうせ年上のお坊さんたちがそこら辺にいるんだからね
まあ一言で問題解決しますけどね
普通の人やっちゃうと
まあこれ喧嘩になって人殺しまで行くかもしれないぐらいもうすごいんです
この自分のね 名前とかなんとかに対する執着っていうのは
である日自分のお寺でこの仏像を置いているこの本堂に
もう昔あるおばあさんがこのちょっと電気一つあの寄付してあったんですね
まあつのもう小さいこのものなんですけど
それ名前書いて 自分の亡くなった息子をなんとかのためにこれを寄付しましたと
で ずいぶん前なんですけど
そこもボロボロボロボロ壊れて壊れて
もうもう何にも使うことはできないんですね
でも本当に出来の悪いあのプラスチックでできてる
ちょっとしたこのライトでしたからね
そこで私から考え これ村人みんなのお寺の本堂だからね
まあものすごい大事なところで
これにはまあもっとしっかりしたもの必要ですよということで修理したんですね
修理にはあれよりはまあもう倍ぐらいお金
私のお金いったんです
で そのついでに僕はこれまあまあまあ修理するなら外すなら外して
外したところでもうさらに壊れたし
捨てなさいと言ったら
まあもう日三日経つと人々が来るんじゃないんですかね
それに文句言うために
だからどこに行った どこら辺にいた人かさっぱりわからなかったんです
ただ それを捨てたということで目が覚めて
もうああ そこら辺にお寺があるんですよと聞いて
道を聞いてくるような感じなんですね
そこでいろんな人々が来て
こういうことであって
その人々はすごくなんか今困ってるんだとか
まあ報告も先から来るんですね
で 報告も先から来ると
私こちらはもうすごく口を準備しているんです
来たらまあ とにかく来る時はね
まあもう誰に見てもすごい綺麗に見えるようにお寺全部もう修復してあって
私は来るって知ってるんだから
じゃああの壊れたもの全部集めてくださいとね
子供たちにきちんとこのめちゃくちゃなあれをちゃんと置いてるんです
どうですか 分かりました
まああの 行ってみてください
違うライトね まあもうつけてますけど
これ外してこれつけますから大丈夫です
安心して帰ってくださいと
で 先にお寺に行って見て
見てもらったんです 見てもらったら
私がつけてるライトっていうのは
あれはかなり高いもので
それもなんかこのそれでも気が済まないんですね
でもあれを捨てて 例えばもう 3万円のライトをつけて
この 100 200円のものつけなさいって言えないでしょうし
ですごくもう言えないので
とにかく喧嘩できないそれで
で行って後で考えて 何を考えたんですけど
それだったらもう一つ古い本堂もありますからね
そちらになんとか寄付しますということで
なんか寄付して 何ライト寄付したいみたいですけどね
分かった だからめんどくさいんですね
やっぱり本堂に入れるんだったら
それなりの豪華なものを入れなくちゃいけないし
自分にもそういうお金もないんだから
別にどうってことないしね
もうやるならばみんなで 20人
50人ぐらい集めて お金集めて豪華なものをつけちゃえば誰にも負担はないし
私の名前をつけなくちゃいけないということだからね
1,000円  2,000円ぐらい払えないし
もう本当に貧しい人々ですから
しょうがないですね だから僕らに別に文句を言うことはできませんだけど
気持ちはわかるんです
同じものだから だからそこまでする必要はないし
その場合で その場合は本人がやっぱりいいことをするつもりなんですけど
自分の名前 自分のことを宣伝してくれる
してくれることにはすごい厳密に執着しているんですね
ですから あれは本当にわからないんです
布施の善行為になるか
お坊さんたちもお寺もいじめて
みんなの修行する場所をね
迷惑をかけてものすごい罪を犯しているかと
どっちかわからないんです
心のからくりっていうのはそんなもんなんですね
だから結局本人がいくらかお金を亡くなったことは確かに亡くなっているんだけど
その代わりに徳を積んだかどうかということはもうわからないんですね
その代わりにお布施もして
その上もう罪も犯したということになる可能性もありますから
そういうわけで この心のからくり
ちゃんと勉強して お布施するならば
お布施になるようにと
徳になるようにと 徳になるんだったら
それはどうしても三因の徳になるようにとした方がもっと利他的ということなんですね
もうさん  それから何でしたっけ
善行為をダーナシン バーヴァナーという 3つあるんだとこっち言ってるんですね
ダーナは布施 シーラは戒
バーヴァナーは瞑想ですね
こちらは修習と書いてあるんですね
その清戒修習という 3つ
ダーナ シーラ バーヴァナー
で ダーナというのはこの体でやること
結局はね シーラで生き方
自分の性格を戒めること
バーヴァナーというのは
修習というのは心を育てること
思考 考え方 心そのもの
そういうふうに 3つに考えているんですね
そういうことで 体をもってする行動はすべてダーナ
布施なんです 何かいいことをすると
自分が自分の体を使っているならば
それは布施です 性格を直そうとする場合は
それは戒律の戒ですね
心を育てよう 育てようと思うならば
それはバーヴァナーです
そういうわけで 世の中で素晴らしい行為だとね
例えば福祉活動やら人助けること
ああだこうだいろんなことを考えているんです
それすべて布施という言葉に入っちゃうんです
ボランティア活動であろうか
病院を作ることであろうか
孤児院を作ることであろうかね
もうなんだかんだで この
いろんな人を助けるためにやっている体を使う行動は何でも布施なんです
それはもう社会的な行動でもあります
でもシーラは社会的な行動じゃないんです
戒は それは個人の問題で
個が自分の生き方 性格をしっかりしようと努力すること
それでどうせ修習もバーヴァナーも個人の行為なんですね
じゃあ次に行きます  23
マカンタン
ニ ダーナシーラバーヴァナアパチャーヤナヴェーリヤワッチャパッティダーナパッターナモダーナダンマサワナダンマデーサナディッティジュカルマヴァセーナダ
サヴィダンホーティタンピパネータンヴィーサティヴィダンピカーマーワチャラカッマンイッチェーヴァサンカンガッチャ
で また別々にわかりやすく
善行為は何でしょうかと 10種類に分けてるんです
そういうのはもう一般的に仏教で有名な言葉なんですね
ダーナ シーラ バーヴァナ
みんなもう暗記しているんです
大体普通は ダーナは布施
シーラは戒律を守ること
バーヴァナは瞑想したり心を育てたりすること
ダーナ シーラ バーヴァナ
3つわかりますね 次にアパチャーヤナ
アパチャーヤナって何ですか？長上の
えっ？どうやって読めるんですか？えっ？恭敬
恭敬 まあその恭敬ですかね
まあ一応アパチャーヤナっていうのは
やっぱり尊敬するべき目上の人々に対して
すごく行儀よく正しく
行動することなんですね
迷惑をかけてはいけないんですけどね
で それはなかなか難しいんです
自分勝手に  その尊敬している人はちゃんと自分が面倒見ているんだと思って
その人に一生懸命迷惑をかけたっても
何の意味もないんですけど
で やっぱり人間っていうのはね
あの 何て言いますかね
まあまあ いろんなことを真似て学んで成長するんだから
導くことはできるのは
やっぱり年上の目上の性格のよろしい人々には他の人々を導くことはできるし
ですから その人々を尊敬しないと
馬鹿にすると決してその自分がいい人間にはならない
それから心の状態から見ても
それは素晴らしい心の状態なんですね
この人は性格が素晴らしいと
その人はすごい道徳的だと
という自分目上のっていうのは
仏教では年上のという意味じゃないんです
いわゆる徳が上ということで
で 親戚同士だったら年上の人は目上なんです
でもそれ以外は世の中はね
ただ年食ったんだからって頭下げる必要ないんですけど
やっぱりそれでもそれなりの尊敬はするべきなんですね
で 性格は素晴らしい人はどうしても年上だと見ているんです
その人々のことを尊敬するということは
大変この自分の心に高慢がないということ
自我がないということ
嫉妬 怒りなんかないということなんです
もし嫉妬や怒りがあったならば
もうできないんですね
で まあ日本ではシステムはぎっしり作ってるんだからそうなりませんだけど
外国なんかは結構自由だから
例えば頭のいい人は勉強できる人はみるみるうちにもう全部勉強し終わっちゃう
終わっちゃうでしょうね
それでも二十歳にもならないうちにすごいところに仕事もし始めちゃうんですね
そうすると 自分の下で働いているのは
みんなもう年取ってる大人たちなんですね
もしその人は若者や青年がとかね
馬鹿にするようになっちゃうとうまくいかないんですね
やっぱりその人々はもういくら年下であろうとも
その人の才能があって能力あるんだから
イエスと言うながらも
言うことはちゃんと命令を聞く
もし自分で私が年上ではないか
私はこの会社に先に入ったのではないかとか
なんかプライドがあったら
その人は自分で会社辞めるしか道がなくなっちゃうんですね
ですからこの やっぱり才能ある人
能力ある人にそれを認める気持ちっていうのは
自分にはプライド 嫉妬ないということなんですね
ですから 嫉妬ない人がすごい柔らかい心を持ってる人は
自分のことを大事に思う人が
自分も育てたいとかね
自分の身を安全にしたいと思う人々は
やっぱり目上の人々を尊敬する
尊敬すると その人々は確実に親切に
その人々の面倒を見てあげるということになるんですね
とにかく仏教ではそれは道徳の一つなんです
ヴェーヤーワッチャっていうのは看病ですね
看病することも大変ないい善行為だと
で 看病の場合は目上か下かってのは関係ないんです
病人であれば あるならば
もうちゃんと看病しましょうと
で こちらパーリ語でヴェーヤーワッチャっていうのは
この あの こちらも日本語でも看病などの作務と書いてあるんですね
だから看病 だけではないんです
で いろいろやらなくちゃいけない
いろんなさしすせみみたいなものを何らかでもやることも素晴らしいことなんですね
あの普通の世俗的な社会では
これはあの人やる仕事
私がやるものじゃないとかね
この仕事に対してすごい上下関係決めちゃうんですね
で 例えば会社の係長は決して茶碗
お茶を洗おうと思わないんですね
もし洗うことになっちゃったら
もう大変なことになるんですね
自分が怒って 自分が爆発して
自分で事故自己破壊するんだけどね
で それは自分やる仕事じゃないんだとかね
そういうのはものすごいもうバカバカらしいんです
その上下関係決めたりとかね
インドでもものすごいありましたからね
だからわざと仏教はそれを批判しているんですね
インドではカースト制度まであるんだからね
もう奴隷 召使いはそのカーストの人々は生まれつき奴隷で召使いでいなくちゃいけない
ある大学にこの低いカーストの人々を入学させたんだということで
学生はインドでね 暴動まで起こしちゃったんですね
だからまあ自分たち まあそういう風にすごい決めつけているんですね
それは良くないと もう仏教はすごく反対しているんです
ですから お釈迦様はどうしようもないんだから
お坊さんたちという別な社会を作っちゃったんですね
別な社会を作って そこの場合は決まりはなんて言いますか
汚れていると見つかった人は綺麗にしなさい
ただそれだけ で 水を水をくんで水入れに入れておくでしょうに
みんなに飲み水やら洗い水とかね
自分が水飲もうと思ったところで水がなかったならば
自分でくんでそれは満杯にしなさい
それだけ それは長老であろうと沙弥であろうと関係ない
で そういう風に決まってるんです
それは私は長老だからそんなことをやってはいけないという沙弥たちに怒ったりするということは大概しない
で かえって沙弥たちに言っているのは
あなた方はちゃんと目上の人を尊敬しなくちゃいけないし
もうもうそういう仕事をしない人はもう決して修行は完成しませんよと言ってるんだから
どうせ若い人々は一生懸命やったりはするんですけど
だからって長老たちもいつでも箒を持ったり
いろんなことを掃除やってるのはいつでも見られるんです
で 沙弥たちなんかあっちこっちでね
綺麗にしているのは見えるかもしれませんだけど
ただ長老何やってる？長老もどこかでなんとかもう一生懸命やってることはもうやってるし
そういう風にこの見た人がやると
という平等な社会なんですね
ですから どんな仕事でも
まあこれはこういうことをやらなくちゃいけないということがあったら
自分の立場とかなんとかとか考えないということ
それで私はこんなことをやるもんじゃないと思ったところで
ものすごい高慢でしょ
自我でしょうに だから自我ある人にはもう仏教も縁も何もないんだから
高慢の人には 私は係長だから茶碗なんかは洗うわけにはいきませんと
お茶入れてはいけないんだと
と思ったら まあそれはもう会社の世界で
仏教の世界では認めないんですね
まあそういうこと で 次にもあまり日本ではないことかもしれませんだけど
なんて言いますか 所得税
所得 所得 所得税と所得税と
所得税は知ってますけど
この まあこれ これパッティダーナなんですね
パッティダーナっていうのは
これ特別な行為なんですね
パッティッパッティっていうのは所得
自分が得たものなんです
それ何ですかというと
この自分が得た財産は誰かにあげるならば布施でしょうし
これも一種の布施なんで
その意味じゃない それは布施で前に入ってましたから
ここで自分がいいことをする
善行為をする それはそれにみんな参加してもらうと
で その場合はこのお金で参加してくださいと言うと
また違うんです 例えば私はこれから大変な良いことをしようとしてるんですけど
あなた方もできるだけ一部一部あの参加してくださいと言ったら
それはみんなでやることであって
そうではなくて 自分がすごくいいことをしたところで
自分を知ってる人やら親戚やらみんなに
まあそれは報告して あなた方もその徳を受けてくださいと
あなた方も喜んでくださいと
自分がやったことをやったことやったのように喜んでくださいと
私はその徳をみんなにあげますと
自分の自慢にするんじゃなくて
私がやったそうとということは
決してこれはみんなのためにやったんだ
みんながやりましたと
そういうふうにこの徳をみんなに配ってあげる
そういう心 だからかなりこのこのこの文脈では
との場合は この自我をなくして
嫉妬をなくして この性格を直そうという働きがすごい厳密に考えてるんです
あなたはいいことをしたんだから
それはあなたのものだという気持ちはもうすごい自我なんですね
ですから 私がいいことをしたんだから
みんなもその喜んでその徳を受けてくださいと
言って 平等に徳を分けてあげると
別に物質的に何か動くわけじゃないんです
それは心のつなぎなんですね
だから自分がみんなと一緒にやりましたと
という気持ち思うこと
で 口でもそれで回向すること
だから回向なんですね
このパッティダーナっていうのは回向すること
だから生きとし生けるものにみんなに回向しますと
こないだテレビ見たんですけど
昼間の小さな村で誰かがコブを
そしたら村の人はみんな一緒にやってるっていう
あれってそういう思想から出て
パッブダーソクティーダ？ 村のね
一人がパブダをする そうすると村の人はみんな一緒にそれに協力してパブダをする
だからそれって今の今の考え方から出てくるんですか
パッティダーナは違いますけど
あの場合はまた違うんですね
あのあれは仏教 一般的なやり方で一人でやるなと
一人でやるよりはみんな参加した方がさらに徳が高いんだと
ということで みんな他の人はもう参加して欲しがるんです
そこもちょっとなからくりだと思いますけど
自分が例えばすごいお金持ってる人は
私は自分一人で作りましょうと思ったら自我強くなっちゃうんですね
それで仏教というのは自分一人でやっちゃったら徳が少ないんだと
それに10人  20人  100人ぐらい参加しちゃったら
さらに徳が高いんだと
だから誰でもたくさん徳をほしがっちゃうんですね
そこで私一人でやるぞではなくて
みんな出てきておいてください
参加してくださいということは言うんです
ですから お金持ちの人が一人で作っても
他の人々は来て ちょっと土一つでも運んであげるとか
そこら辺ちょっと掃除してあげるとか
あるいは道具ぐらい貸してあげるとか
自分にできることは何とかしてあげる
その人もすごくありがたいございますという感じで
その参加を認めるということなんですね
ですから 物はみんなでやるんだと
一緒にやるんだと 一人だけはもう出しゃばってやるものではないということは
またすぐあるんです それはみんなでやるということで
パッティダーナの場合は
個人が 例えばたまたま私が何かいいことをしたとする
他の人にはなかなか参加できなかった可能性もあるし
それでどうしても個人個人でいいことをしているんだから
あの場合もその個人たちも徳を積んでいるし
その個人たちがまたお互いにパッティダーナする
回向するんです 私が得た徳を皆様にあげるんだと
その他の人々も私が得た徳もみんなにあげるんだというやりとりをやるんです
だから あまりこれは現代社会的に美しくやってないだけで残念ですけど
本当は素晴らしい行為だと思います
で 我々沙弥たちに お坊さんたちのやりとりでは必ずそれをやるんです
例えば沙弥が戒律を受けなくちゃいけないでしょうし
その時は沙弥が来てずっとこの文章でお願いするんですね
そのお願いの中でも 私が今までやった全ての徳を先生にあげます
回向しますと 私も先生が今までやってきた徳を全部受け取りますと
ということでやりとりをして
で これから私に戒律を授けてくださいというふうに文章でやらなければ
文章まで決まってるんです
で 例えばお坊さんたちの中でも
お互いにいつでも謝ることがありまして
謝る文句があるんです
で 挨拶するということは謝るんですね
で 文句は決まっていて
その謝る文句の中でも徳は全部私の徳は全部差し上げますと
私が積んだ徳を差し上げますと
私も先生積んだ徳をいただきますというふうなやりとりをやってるんですね
ですから そこで何か素晴らしく
この何か自我がない世界
だから誰がいっぱい徳積んだかとか消えちゃうんですね
みんな一緒なんですね
その気持ちになればね
すごい高いレベルで修行したお坊さんにしても
そのお坊さんが一生懸命一人で修行してるんだけど
結局私の徳をみんなに差し上げますと言ってますから
その人々もそれはものすごいサードサードという言葉で受けてるならば
それでもOKになっちゃうんですね
だからすごくこのお釈迦様の時代から美しい平等の社会に自我のない個人がね
もう徹底的に出て出よう出ようとしない社会を考えてはいたんですね
いくらかはそういう国々ではあるんですね
だからあまりこの混乱は今までなかったんですね
だから昔の文化だったら
例えば村で一人だけすごい金持ちが出てくると
その人のことを嫉妬しないんです
その代わりに村人ってすごい喜んじゃうんです
これはあの人の土地で
あの人の家で あの人の財産だよと
村人みんなそれで威張っちゃうんですね
それで威張れるんです
なぜかというと 村の一人がすごい豊かで金持ちであるということは
村のみんなの面倒見るんです
何のこともなく だからこの自分の国の場合なんですけど
昔の人々 大きな家なんかある場合はこんな鍵とかないんです
で 普通の人々は裏から裏面から何のことなく家に入って
それぞれいろいろお手伝いをしたりして
そこでご飯も食べたりして
また帰っちゃうし また何か仕事終わったらそれなりの人々が来てやったりする
その人は村人のことを全部知ってるんです
ですから もうその人は金持ちは金持ちなんですけど
それなりにお互いにこの面倒見合うとかという気持ちがあって
なんか嫌な存在ではないんですね
で そこはこの現代文明が出てきちゃうと
やっぱり金持ちは全部鍵をかけて入るなと
来るなというふうなことになっちゃって
嫌な存在なんですね そうすると嫉妬が生まれる
怒りが生まれる あいつらが商売して金儲けてとかなんとか
そういう気持ちになってしまっちゃうし
それでもう破壊しなくちゃいけなくなっちゃう
それで共産主義が出てくるし
搾取がああだこうだとかね
仏教の世界ではそんな搾取とかそんなもんありえないんですね
ですから この結構 まあそういう社会っていうのはね
昔もそれ問題っていうのは
この仏教社会はこのなかなか現代解釈というかね
現代社会に持ってくると
このうまくこの変化させなかったんですね
そこで止まってしまっちゃうんだからね
だからそれは仏教の間違ってるところもありますけど
やっぱり社会は時代は変わるんだから
それは誰にも止まられませんし
ヨーロッパ文明は強力になってきてね
まあそれはみんな世界を抑えると
それはどうしようもないかもしれませんだけど
そうするとこちらもそれなりに進化しなくちゃいけないんですね
文教文化っていうのはそれに対立して
それだったらよかったんだけど
あまりそこら辺はね 考えてないというかね
手を引くというか まるごとに向こうの文化はもう受け取るかどっちかになっちゃいますけど
まあとにかくこのパッティダーナっていうのは回向すること
次にやるのはパッターヌモーダナ
パッターヌモーダナってのは逆
人の徳を自分で受けること
アヌモーダナっていうのは
まあこうやって随喜という感じ入れてますけど
これもまああの あ それはよろしいと自分も喜ぶことなんです
認めることなんですね
で 意味としては うーん
やっぱり受け取るという意味なんですね
ですから 自分がいいことをしたら
それはみんなに あなた方にもこの回向しますと言ったら
受け取りますと この気持ちよく
あ それは素晴らしいことで
私もあなたの徳を受け取りますと
受け入れますと と思って
自分もやったことと同じく喜びを感じる
自分でやったように それも大変な難しいことなんです
だから偉そうに人に回向します
私には人の徳は要りませんと言っちゃったら
これも大乗仏教みたいになっちゃいますけどね
それすごい そうじゃなくて
私もみんなの徳を気持ちよく受け
受け入れます で なかなかその気持ちにはなるのは難しいんです
例えば 人が一生懸命いいことをしているのを見て
あの徳で私も幸福でありますようにと思われませんね
で やっぱりそのやり方というのは
それを批判しないで ああ素晴らしい
素晴らしいと なんと素晴らしいんだろう
と自分で心で喜ぶを喜びを感じると
受けることになるんです
例えば人がね ちょっといいことをしたら
なんだそれぐらいのことでっていうのは
もう全く受け取るんじゃなくても否定してるんですね
ですから 心込めて それは本当に大したことですね
立派なものですと認めることなんですね
100円寄付したんだと
もうたとえ 100円だってても
寄付したことはすごいことですよと
たとえ 100円も入りませんでしたから余計なんですけどね
あなたもすごいいいことに参加しましたと
素晴らしいと いうふうに思う気持ちは必要なんです
だからそれもできると
また我々の性格が直るんですね
我々にはすごい悪い煩悩がいくつあるんですね
他人の徳を消す 他人を軽視する
それで自分の徳をないものを強調して見せるという悪い煩悩 2つあるんです
それはもうこれでなくなっちゃうんですね
人がいいことをしちゃったら
どこかでケチをつけたくなっちゃうんですね
ああ それぐらいですかとね
なんだそんなもんかと
いうふうな気持ちがあるし
そこで自分がつまらないことをしたっても
それをすっごく私はこういうことをやってるんだよとか
もう巨大に風船みたいに膨らまして見せたがる
その 2つの煩悩をこの働きで消えちゃうんです
ですから パッティパッターのモードな回向することと
他人の徳を自分でも受けることも善行為だと言っているんです
次にダンマサヴェーナ
法門かな 聴聞 聞法 法を聞くこと
法を聞くと 聞くだけで心は喜ぶし
心は綺麗になるんですね
法っていうのは世間話ではないし
漫才でもないし もう何かのね
経済的な商売はどうしますかとかね
1週間でどのように億万長者になるかという話ではないんだから
やっぱり心のことを説明しているし
ですから聞くだけでもかなり心は整理されて綺麗になって大変な徳なんですね
法を聞くことは 同じく説法も
人に法を説くことも大変な徳なんです
最後にあるのは すごい日本語ですね
見直後 建築業みたいですけど
ディッティジュカンマというんですね
ディッティっていうのは
仏教のいろんな概念たくさんあるんだけど
あまりにも幅広くて深くて
すぐわかるっていうことはないんです
これもすべての真理だから
ものすごい膨大な量あることは確かにあるんですね
ですから あっちこっちでもうしっかりしないところもありますから
自分知ってることを自分理解していることとか
いつでも考え直したりしたりして
勉強し直したりして いつでも綺麗に磨いておくと
放っておけば どんどんどんどん堕落して
この錆びてしまっちゃうんですね
どんな意見でも どんな考え方でも
ですから よくよく自分の考え方
意見 生き方 特に仏教に対する考え方ですね
他のことじゃないんです
いつでもやり直して 聞き直して
考え直して 磨いて磨いて
さらにさらに強くすると
という 10種類の徳行があるんです
結構考えで作っているものなんです
作っているということが言うのは失礼ですけど
このディッティジュカンマでは
この建築 建築じゃなくて見直後ではね
心っていうのは やっぱり汚れちゃうし
邪見に陥っちゃうし もし自分がわずかに仏教のことを知ってるんだと
機には行ってるんだと
そこである人がすごい強力にものすごい迫力があって
違う宗教のがあんた知ってますか？あの人はこういう奇跡を起こしてますよと言っちゃったら
なんとなく自分がもう圧倒されちゃって
じゃあ行きましょうと行っちゃうと
行ける 行ってしまうんですね
心っていうのはそういうふうなものなんですね
奇跡を起こしてますからと何とか言ったら
ですから このきちんと真理を